on the shoreline at Prestwick beach 14
years ago this month the body of a
Swedish woman was found face down in the
sand the death of 30 year old Annie
Boursin was recorded as suicide her
family on so sure an eight-part
investigation by the sky news podcast
series three cast has looked into the
life and mysterious death of Annie
Boursin the post-mortem conducted in
Scotland recorded the cause of Annie's
death as drowning there were minor
injuries on her body but police were
satisfied they had been caused by coming
into contact with rough objects in the
water it was only when Annie's body was
returned to Sweden that Undertaker's
made a discovery that shocked her family
the Bruce to the head and indicate that
she had been done hardened by someone
investigative journalist marchello mega
is one of few people to have seen
Annie's post-mortem photographs it was a
massive bruise to the temple and which
immediately said to me that she had been
struck very hard probably by a blunt
instrument the sort of blow that would
knock most people unconscious I would
think and there was also significant
bruising to her arms on the day she was
last seen Annie had traveled to preswick
airport from Edinburgh where she lived
she had her passport and entered the
airport terminal building not left
without buying a ticket standing by the
water's edge and looking out to sea
Andrew Montgomery told police at the
time he thought the figure he'd seen on
a distant shore line was a woman 14
years on reflections don't fit the
conclusion it was Annie it's really
unreflecting I think the light was still
Perla I couldn't be absolutely certain
it was a woman
Scotland's grown officer said Annie's
death was thoroughly investigated after
detailed consideration of the facts and
circumstances it says the Procurator
Fiscal concluded there were no
suspicious circumstances and as there
were no systemic defects which
contributed to the death
there was no basis to hold a fatal
accident inquiry Annie's family say it
leaves fundamental questions unanswered
about just what did happen to their
daughter in the moments before her death
here 14 years ago James Matthews Sky
News Prestwick